Woaaaaaaahh, whooo
Wow
Hey whats up guys! it is good to see you again in today's video. We're getting crazy with chemical experiments, now for this video
I was scrolling through the comments and I found this request from Spoon Kapeezi
Who says if you mix brake fluid and chlorine the mixture will self ignite. This is an experiment
You may be familiar with by now, but I think the real request is to push the experiment to the boundaries and explain
What's actually taking place, now to get the chemicals we need for our experiment today
I made two quick pit stops the first one was to a pool supply store to pick some of this fast
dissolving shock treatment for swimming pools and the second stop was to the auto parts store to pick up some dot 3 brake fluid
I'm Reading the warning label and funny enough
It doesn't say anywhere on here that you can't mix with pool chlorine, does that mean we can?
Well Let me show you what happens if you do, you might have noticed on the bag of pool shock chlorine it contains 73 percent calcium Hypochlorite
so really high concentration of available chlorine the brake fluid is a mixture of ethylene Glycols
And when you mix these two chemicals together a very interesting reaction occurs
now if we snip the end off of our pool chlorine and pour out the contents you can see it's really just a
Granulated white powder and if you're standing too close, it'll start to smell like a swimming pool
And you might even feel it starting to sting your nostrils
So here's the setup guys
I just fill up this glass about half an inch full at the bottom with Pool shock chlorine
And I've got our dot 3 brake fluid we're ready to pour in we're going to carefully add our brake fluid in equal proportions so that
It comes just the top the chlorine then we're going to give it a little shake set it down on the top of this brick
And start a timer and then get very very far away for about 2 minutes
Now once these two chemicals mixed together. It doesn't really look like anything is happening. It's just sitting there. There's no smoke
There's no steam
It just sits there doing nothing and we're over a minute in twenty seconds now and nothing is really changed, but watch this
Bangerang baby, did you see that?
It'sat there for about one minute and 35 seconds, and it looked like it was doing absolutely nothing is was completely calm
No smoke and then just out of nowhere
boom the whole thing combusts a flame shoots up about four feet in the air and we get all this ash that bubbles up and
Spews over the Edge that was an epic reaction, so let's do one more of those and then talk about what's happening
Nothing like the itchy sensation of chlorine in the nostrils in the morning. It's what I do for you guys
If you looked down at this, it looks like nothing is happening whatsoever. It's just sitting there. You don't see any smoke
No, Heat if I feel the glass I don't even feel it warming up
Ocassionally a little bubble, but I think that's just cuz of the oil sinking now, but we do want to get very far away
We want to back up and just watch it patiently because the reaction is taking place watch this
So we just passed a minute now since we added the brake fluid and absolutely nothing's happening. It's just sitting there
it's just sitting there silently like a crocodile waiting for the kill
but Something's going to happen just wait for it.
It's a minute and 30 seconds
Man that stuff shot right at the top
I think that wasn't even bigger flaming that time that one shot up about five feet high and it was right at the 1 minute
35 second mark which is very consistent to the first test that we did
So now that we verified that this reaction works. It works very consistently
I reached out to my friend nurdrage for an explanation of what's taking place, and he gave me some really good insight
I think we should talk about now on the warning label here
It says that our brake fluid is a mixture of glycol ethers basically long
Hydrocarbons very similar to oil the difference being that brake fluid has oxygen inserted every two carbons now
Technically this fluid is flammable, but it's very very hard to ignite
And that's why it's generally considered safe for use with your brakes
Now the actual reaction taking place when the brake fluid makes contact with the pool chlorine is a free radical break down at the Polyethylene
Glycol it basically breaks the Glycol down into lighter components like aldehydes now this takes time
Which is why the reaction doesn't begin right away?
But as the simpler aldehydes build up they start reacting with the oxygen in the pool chlorine to form water and carbon dioxide
Is basically a simple combustion reaction the reaction is exothermic and produces a tremendous amount of heat to the point where it actually?
Vaporizes the aldehydes and burst into flame. Yes
It actually gets so hot that the brake fluid
Vapors self ignite if you were to put this reaction inside of a sealed container the container would explode now
Let's talk for just a second about the white vapors coming off of this reaction
I've heard concerns from some people wondering that toxic chlorine gas now chlorine is very discernible
It's very toxic it starts stinging your nose and your lungs
Immediately with very low concentration and during all these experiments and reactions that I've tried the smell of chlorine is Negligible
I actually get a stronger smell of chlorine when I'm just pouring the powder into the glass itself the white fumes
we're seeing are actually broken down and vaporized brake fluid those are the flammable vapors that burst into fire as soon as the temperature -
Todd now let's set up two more experiments just to see how this reacts in different scenarios
one out in the open air and the other in the confined space of a soda bottle
Okay, so that was a little bit surprising
I thought out in the open air would actually take longer to react but actually went off in 54 seconds. That's really interesting
Nice chemical residue now my friend Marcus brought up a good point
Don't stir the stuff up with your fingers guys because any chemical residues can ignite and burn your skin, okay?
So we've seen this reaction in a glass we've seen it in the open air our last experiment is in a plastic soda bottle I
Just think I'm just going to give this one a little bit too much
Much too much
Just for the record that is way too much this should be fun
fourth and final
Here we go
This one might happen a little fast
Maybe not there's one minute oh
wow, oh
my goodness, holy heck
Okay, so what was really interesting about that. It was still only about a minute and 30 seconds the same was our other reaction
but the difference is the flame shot out like
Rocket fuel the color of the flame itself was like a deep red or Magenta and it shot up
Ridiculously high I mean it it almost looked like a rocket engine turned upside down not quite as much power of course but very very
Satisfying and it was like shooting hot chlorine tablets into the air and they were raining down the back of my shirt
Which is absolutely nuts. I'm actually quite surprised that took that long for the reaction to start because in a confined container
I would have expected the heat to build a little bit more quickly
But that was very consistent with the other reactions that we've experimented with today
The thing is when it goes off in the bottle
It's just a lot more violent imagine if that were capped off who have bottle bar on our hands
What's really amazing to me is how deceiving this reaction is like it
Just sits there nothing's happening at all and then out of nowhere
Bam this huge fireball super violent reaction is you don't want to be standing anywhere near that's amazing
You only get like a split-second with white vapor coming out of the bottle and then boom the whole thing ignites the bottle completely
illuminates
and then you see this fire stack just shooting out of the top and
that right there is where it gets extremely violent the flame shoots out of
Frame and starts spewing chemical into the air raining down ashes everywhere
Man it goes from the stream of fire to like a blowtorch excellent seriously
That's a lot of fire the other thing that you notice is the plastic bottle shrinks like the heat of the reaction
shrinks the plastic and then catches in a fire where just burns away to nothing so
Very intense experiment to say the least not an experiment need to try at home
It's one of those things where the manufacturer says use the product only as intended for these kinds of reasons
So kind of fun experiments here guys let's talk about what just happened
We started off our experiment today with pool shot chlorine and dot 3 brake fluid those specific chemicals when mixed together
Start an exothermic reaction that disassociates the polyethylene glycol into lighter and much more flammable
Aldehyde when this exothermic reaction accelerates enough
It'll eventually hit the point where the brake flew will vaporize and those flammable vapors will self ignite, and we tried three different scenarios
we stuck this combination in a glass out in the open air and in a soda bottle and
Surprisingly we found that the reaction in the open air went off quicker than the ones in the confined spaces
Which is exactly opposite of what I would have expected
So there we have a guides based on our experiments today
We now have a deepened
Understanding as to why mixing different chemicals together can lead to disastrous results and are often not recommended to be tried at home
And of course a huge shout-out to spoon Capisi for leaving the suggestion in the first place and to all
580 of you who uploaded it go ahead and check your youtube inbox spoon or sending a 25 bucks?
Hey, thanks for joining me for this experiment. I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then
interesting chemical residue you
Can hear the comments?
Global warming
Hey guys, I want to jump back in for just a second to invite you to come follow me on Instagram
I've got a very active page where I post daily pictures and stories of behind the scenes and every day's an adventure
Just take five seconds right now to click the link in the description to come follow me on Instagram at the king of random
I'll see you there